okay uh great um welcome to the class uh
uh super uh super exciting week week
with some uh really exciting topics uh
for us to cover so now for the topic for
today we are going to talk about uh
recommender systems and we are also
going to talk about how can graph
learning be applied to uh recommander
systems and before I kind of start we
are going to look even what is a
recommendation recommender system task
how it's defined and how do we uh
evaluate it but the main motivation for
recommendation is that in this uh mainly
in the online world where you can
basically have huge inventory of things
and the inventory of things that you
have is not limited by you know some
kind of physical store something that
user can navigate or a library but you
can essentially have unlimited inventory
the the problem then becomes how do
people find things they are looking for
or things that they like and usually
right like when you say I want people to
find one option is that they explicitly
tell you what they want and you you give
it to them that is a search engine type
metaphor um but another type of a
metaphor is also that you want to see
what the what things the user has
consumed in the past and based on that
you want to recommend new things new
that the user was not aware but might be
suitable for the user and you can think
of anything from movies in Netflix to
products in in Amazon to to music to
videos to pins um and and many many
other things all right and the point of
this is that we want these things to be
personalized right they they should be
different for for every human because
different humans are different they have
different needs different tastes and so
on right so we want to suggest a small
number of interesting items to each user
um and this is kind of critical from
user
satisfaction point of view and the
utility they get out of that uh platform
Service uh whatever uh whatever whatever
it is okay and the way we can model
recommender systems as a graph we can uh
we can model them as a bipartite graph
where we have users on one side and we
have items on the other side and what
you can also do um many times do and
basically all big um especially
e-commerce companies have huge efforts
that they build a knowledge graph on
this side right you can think about here
how the knowledge graph can extend if
these are movies what are properties of
the movies Cate categories actors genres
and so on and you can have a knowledge
graph on this side what you can also do
on the user side is that it's not only
that you know user and the items the
user uh interacted let's say purchased
or or browsed but but also you have
other information about the user other
behavior on the site that you can kind
of enrich with the graph on on the on
the uh on the um uh left hand side right
so the but the most simple
representation is that you have users
and items and uh an edge means that a
user has let's say consumed uh that
given item right so uh The Edge
indicates some kind of user item
interaction maybe a click maybe a
purchase maybe a review um and it's
often associated with a time stamp
because this interaction between a user
and an item happened at at a particular
point in time so the the the most kind
of General way to to write out the
recommender system task is that we have
some users and we have some items and we
have some of this information this
interactions known from the past um and
the task is that you want to predict new
items uh each user is going to interact
with in the future right um and this we
can think of this as a link prediction
problem right where you want to predict
new new user item interaction edges
based on the past edges right so for a
given user U and for a given uh item v
we need to get a real valued score that
would kind of say what is the utility of
this user with respect to that uh item
and item can be something very abstract
can be a product can be a movie can be a
restaurant can be a dish at a restaurant
can be a a movie director can be a taxi
ride can be a decision whether you want
to order food or you want to take a taxi
ride or you want some other service so a
lot of different things you can think
about something recommending something
to the user and trying to anticipate
what the user is going to do a modern
recommender system is a is kind of is a
is a is a big is a big system it has
many components and one of the main
problems is that many time like in
reality we cannot evaluate this function
f this utility function for every user
item pair right like you cannot show up
to the Amazon web page and in 50
milliseconds score How likely are you to
be interested at this time you know on
Tuesday at 3:09 p.m. uh for each of the
100 million products they have or how
many even more and then show you top 20
or somehow decide what to show you right
so usually the way this works is that
you have a two-stage process so you have
what they call candidate generation and
then you have a ranking and a candidate
generation the idea is that basically
you use the user as a query into your uh
database of items and you retrieve um
the closest uh the most relevant items
maybe 100 maybe thousand of them and
then you come with a big fat um ranking
uh stage that now scores every of those
thousand items with with respect to the
user and in a recommender system usually
you would have a lot of different
candidate generators and that that look
at various aspects and then you'd have
let's say one scoring function so in the
in the embedding world when we work with
embeddings the idea is that you
basically use you somehow embed a user
and the embedding of the user is your
query and then you have a KN andn means
K nearest neighbor engine where you
basically take this embedding the query
and you say what are 100 or thousand
nearest item embeddings to the embedding
of the user and you retrieve those so
this is like a high dimensional search
engine it's actually the way the way
this works it uh it's interesting the
the the state-of-the-art methods for
retrieval these nearest neighbor engines
are graph based called H&S W is the
method hierarchical small world networks
is the method right but you you retrieve
here from Millions tens of millions
billions of items you have your
candidates and now you are scoring these
thousand candidates with respect to the
user and then return let's say top 10
and really in reality you never return
top 10 because out of the highest
ranking ones you're like which ones has
the user seen yesterday ahuh those I
throw away I want some diversity so I'll
show you know five five examples of this
side and of this type and I'll show
another five examples of that type and
somebody's paying me to show that item
so it's an ad and I'll throw that in
there so there is a lot of there's a lot
of logic that goes on in here from you
know you scoring to actually user seeing
it but you know that's maybe uh if you
are interested more in this next quarter
I'll be teaching two CS 246 and we'll
talk more in depth about recommander
systems but it's it's a super
fascinating area Okay so search and then
I recommend okay so the point is that
for each user we want to recommend in
this kind of uh K items where K is let's
say 10 or 100 right and we uh the
recommendation to be effective K needs
to be much smaller than the total number
of items I have in my database right so
usually we recommend let's say 10 items
to the user and then see what the user
does with the 10 items and as soon as
the user Scrolls we recommend the next
10 and the user Scrolls and the next 10
because we want to be very real time we
want to be very responsive to the user
it makes no sense to use yes you know
your engagement from last week to
materialize recommendations for next
week it's it's stale so we want to be
kind of responsive right uh and the goal
is to include as many of these positive
items as possible in the into the K top
K recommended items so what do I mean
here is that a positive item is item
that the user will interact with in the
future right so the idea is that
basically I want to predict what items
you are going to uh to interact with
next week and uh I want today to guess
as many of those items as possible the
evaluation metric that people would call
would call talk about is they would call
it recall at K or they would call hits
at K so out of topk items that you
recommended how many has the user
actually interacted with in the next
time period so the way you can think of
this is that for every user p subu is a
set of positive items that the user will
interact in the future right now of
course you can say okay how do I know
what the user will interact in the
future the way you know it is that you
pretend that today's February 1 and then
you look what the user does in the week
of February 1st to February 2nd right so
you you go into the history and you hide
the future from yourself and see can you
predict that future that's the way you
know what the user will do right um and
let R subu be the set of items
recommended by our model right so the
topk recommendations um right that that
um and we want to um items that the user
has already interacted with we want to
exclude so the point is that um we want
to maximize the size of the intersection
right we want uh out of the items to
recomend that we recommend as many of
them as possible to be the ones that the
user has uh uh interacted with in the in
the uh in the future so this is called
recal recall at K and it's simply the
intersection between these two sets
divided by uh the the fraction of
positive uh positive items and the
higher value indicates that more
positive items are recommended uh to the
user um and the final recall is computed
by averaging the recall values across
all users right so the unit of
recommendation is a user it's a it's I'm
recommending it to a user I'm
recommending it in a session okay so um
this is what I want to say kind of from
what is the goal of a Rec Commander
system so now let's talk about embedding
based methods for recommander systems
the notation I'm going to use is the
following U is a set of users V is a set
of uh
items and e is a set of observed user
item interactions right so in some sense
a set of edges between users and items
where an edge means that user U
interacted with item v so now you know
what is an interaction in this uh
simplified case let's assume an
interaction is I bought an item I liked
an item something of that sort right
some positive action that I did uh with
the item I watched the movie and so on
right and then um yeah this is kind of
domain specific and very important how
you define this positive interaction
right with the movie You' usually say oh
you watched 80% of the movie um and and
so on okay so that's uh uh that's what
we say and now what is the scoring
function the scoring function is we want
to get the topk items so we need to a
score function that scores a user comma
item um and gives me a score so um I'll
write it this way score between a user
and an item um and I'm going to return
the the K items with the largest scores
for a given user right again excluding
already interacted items uh at the time
of recommendation right so the idea is
that for a given user I'm going to score
all possible items here are their scores
and then and then I'm going to return
top K where K is some hyper parameter
okay that's what's conceptually
happening um and a me and a a method
that works really really well are based
on embeddings and the reason these
methods work really well is because
usually you have a lot of this uh this
interaction data and because you have a
lot of this interaction data you can
really learn this kind of optimal
embeddings about of users and items so
you can then um uh learn basically their
different aspects and make good
recommendation so for our case for every
user we are going to have a d
dimensional embedding and for every item
we are going to have a d dimensional
embedding and then I'm going to have
some scoring function f parameterized by
this parameters data that is you know
going to take embedding of the user
embedding of the item and will return me
a score okay and that will be uh in some
sense a utility uh that of a user with
respect to a given
item um and this means that embeding
based methods are going to have three
types of parameters that I'll need to
learn or estimate I need an encoder to
generate user embeddings I need a way I
need a set of parameters or an encoder
to generate item embeddings and then I
also need a parameters sta of the
scoring function so I can learn a
scoring function I learn the embeddings
of users and embeddings of items and the
training objective is that I want to
optimize the model parameter
to achieve High recall at K on scene
user item interactions on the training
user item interactions right and the
hope is that this objective would also
lead to high recall at k for the Unseen
future uh interactions that's that's
kind of the the what we are trying to
achieve there is one problem with this
recall at K the problem is that this
original objective function is
nondifferentiable right you cannot I
cannot apply gradient based learning to
it I cannot apply optimization methods
to it so that's a problem so what what
you do in practice is that people have
developed two surrogate uh loss
functions that are widely used and
enable efficient gradient based learning
right basically I can do back
propagation I can use SGD Adam and so on
right and there are two ways how people
do this one is called a binary loss and
the other one that's better is called
basian personalized ranking loss or BPR
so I'll expl explain this one quickly
and then the the and what the problem is
with binary loss and then I'll show you
the BPR um the point is that this
arrogate losses are differentiable um
and uh they you know in some sense
should align well with the original
training objective of that or training
goal of optimizing for recol at K so
what is a binary loss a binary loss we
Define positive and negative uh edges
you know a set of positive edges e are
the observed training user item
interaction so this is what the user is
going to interact with in the future and
then we have a set of negative edges
which are interactions that are not
going to happen uh in the
future okay now how do you select this
um becomes very important um in practice
because um you won't be able to use all
non-existent interactions as negatives
um and you have to be careful how you
select negative examples right if I'm
uh you know really excited about baking
then if you pick 100 random Amazon
products as negative examples probably
none of them will be about baking you
know there' be a car there be a toy
there be I know some dress and so on it'
be very easy to say oh yeah Ur is not
interested in that he really is into
baking right it will be too easy so
there is um as I'll show you towards the
towards the end for some let's say
commercial um uh recommender systems
that are deployed there's a lot of uh
thinking that goes into this negative uh
example selection now that I defined e
and e negative I'll just Define a
sigmoid function a sigmoid function is a
function that takes an input on the real
axis and squishes it between zero and
one so why do we like Sigma function
because now if things are on zero and
one I can interpret this as a
probability okay so that's that's all it
takes a real axis and squishes it in in
a in a um in a bjective way to a
interval zero in one right so Maps real
Valu scores into something that can be
interpreted as a binary likelihood score
right like as a probability so a binary
loss is the following right it's a it's
a binary classification of positive
negative edges using my scoring function
f so it's basically a cross entropy loss
that's another way right so I'm saying
here are my uh positive edges it's a sum
over my positive edges and it's the the
log the log sigmoid of the score so it's
basically the log probability right I'm
just multiplying or summing up this log
probabilities for edges that actually
occur so I will want this to be um as as
small as possible right and then um I go
here over the negative edges so the
edges that did not appear what I want to
maximize uh here I want to do one minus
the probability of an edge right so
really I want this uh this scores to be
as small as possible so that you know uh
something if it's small as negative as
possible then a sigmoid of that will be
close to zero um one minus something
close to zero will be close to one log
of one is zero right so that's that's
what I want I want this uh log terms to
be as small as possible and I want uh
this this terms to be as as big as
possible as close to one as possible
while here I want this as as close to
zero uh as as possible right and that
that means that this uh binary loss
pushes the scores of positive examples
higher than those of uh negative
examples or negative edges and this
aligns well with our recall metric right
we want the interactions in the future
to get high score and the negative
interactions to get uh low score one
detail is that usually um during
training these terms you don't really go
over all the positive edges and all the
negative edges but you create mini
batches right and uh you can basically
approximate this loss by using mini
batches of positive and negative
examples and and many times people would
maybe sometimes change only maybe have
one positive example in a mini batch and
a lot of negative examples and sometimes
because sampling negative examples can
take a lot of time you would even use
the same set of negative examples across
a few min batches and then refresh them
so there's a lot of tricks that people
do to make this work for you know
hundreds of millions billions of users
or items the issue with this binary loss
is that it scores uh all uh all positive
edges and and uh tries to push them high
and it pushes all the negative edges uh
low right what do I mean by here this is
our all edges UV and this is our all
edges UV right so the problem is it
tries to put all positive edges high and
all negative edges low uh but this would
kind of unnecessarily penalize a model
predictions even if the training recall
metric is perfect okay so let me show
you an example of what I mean by this
what I mean is the following imagine I
have two users and two items and imagine
user one user zero likes item zero and
user one likes item one and imagine my
scoring function would say there is a
score four on this edge and a score of
two on the other Edge okay so um uh uh
here right so it means that the the pink
Edge is ranked higher than the edge
between one and item zero and for the
user Zero The Edge between user zero and
item zero is has score one and the other
the other Edge to the item one has a
score of minus one so this would be a
perfect recall but if you look at what
the the training law the binary loss
would do it would penalize you because
you have ranked uh uh this Negative Edge
you gave it a score of two while that
positive Edge has a score of one so you
would receive uh you would receive
penalty right so the problem is that
binary loss would still penalize the
model because the negative uh Edge has a
higher score than this positive Edge
even though they come from different
users and if you look at each user
individually the ranking of the edges is
actually correct okay so that's the
problem with the binary loss so the the
the Insight is that the binary loss is
non-personalized in a sense that
positive negative edges are considered
ac across all users at once right um but
the recall metric that I defined is
inherently personalized it's per user
recall right um and uh uh in some sense
this uh uh non-personalized
binary loss is kind of overly stringent
for measuring personalized recall metric
so a suitable alternative to this that
makes this fix is um is a loss function
that basically is uh personalized what
do I mean by this is that for each user
we want the scores of the positive items
to be above the scores of the negative
items for each user separately
regardless of what is the magnitude of
the scores uh for one user versus the
other user right we don't core the the
the the we don't care about the ordering
of scores across users and the BPR the
basian personalized ranking loss
achieves this so let me show you what
this uh loss is so um one thing here's a
note this BPR was was uh invented back
in 2009 um and at that point in time
they they called it basian because they
had some basian priors uh as part of
their model but it turns out you don't
really that the key Innovation was not
the basium priors but was this uh
personalized ranking and people still
call it basian personalized ranking even
though it's the personalized ranking
that is important here okay so just to
explain why basian is there even though
it kind of shouldn't be um so the point
being is that this loss is personalized
surrogate loss that aligns well with
this recall at okay and the way it works
is the following is that for every user
we will now Define a set of positive and
negative edges right so rather than
saying here are all the positive edges
and here are all the negative edges now
we are going to have positive and
negative set for every user so um now
notice that I have a set of positive
edges that is a function of the user and
a set of negative edges that is a
function of the user okay before we just
said there are negative edges now this
negative set will be different depending
on what what user I'm I'm thinking about
okay so this is and notice here when I
give the definitions I always kind of
condition on this on this user I say
these are the positive interactions of
this given user and these are the non-
interactions or negative edges of this
given user okay so the the training
objective then is that for each user you
star we want scores um of the rooted
positive edges rooted in a sense that
the that left hand side of the edge is
fixed the user is fixed to be higher
than those of the rooted negative edges
right um and the way you write this down
is
here where I'm saying I'm going over
every pos positive Edge and every
Negative Edge for a given user and then
here I'm saying for a positive Edge it
has to be ranked higher than all the
negative edges right because I take a
positive Edge and then I go over all the
negative edges and here I take the
difference in ranking this is the
positive and this is a negative right so
now if the score if the score um of the
of the positive guy is always bigger
than the score of any negative uh Edge
for uh for a given uh for a given for a
given user then this difference will be
positive then this sig this sigmoid will
give me something that is uh above above
uh zero um and uh things will uh things
will uh work out okay so the final BPR
loss will be um will be will be one one
over number of users and then you are
kind of summing this loss over all the
users where the loss is defined here and
then again um the the uh the point here
is that you can approximate this again
using mini bches and so on but the key
is that you are now
comparing the difference between a
positive interaction and a negative one
for a fixed user okay and only then you
sum up or average over all the users you
have okay um now one thing about these
BPR laws that I that I want to say is
that in practice you want to do this
over mini batches so this means that um
we sample a subset of users you for a
given for a given mini batch and then
for uh each user we sample one positive
item um in uh for for each user in the
mini batch we sample one positive item
um and a set of negative items okay um
and then in the the mini badge the loss
would be computed uh as as follows right
so this is I average over all the users
in the mini
batch um I go over the negative edges
and I'm saying the difference I'm I have
this difference between the users's
positive item there is only one and a
set of negative items for that fixed
user okay so now I have one positive and
a set of negatives for uh for every for
every user in that mini batch and
whenever the the the the uh um uh uh in
the next mini batch I may have the same
the same user but I'll have a different
positive item and a different set of uh
negative items uh that's the idea so let
me summarize what we have learned so far
we have learned that this recall at K is
a metric for personalized
recommendation um and uh we talked that
there are basically the way you could
build a recommander system is that
basically that you would learn three
types of parameters this could be
shallow embeddings a user encoder item
encoder and a scoring function um and I
showed you the surrogate loss functions
either a binary or this personalized
ranking loss that basically allow you
now to optimize the loss in order for
you to learn these
parameters um and generally in this
recommender system benchmarks so this is
benchmarks the embedding based models
have achieved uh kind of
state-of-the-art performance uh so now I
want to explain why do they work so well
in this um in this uh benchmarks
question why are you always samp many
more negative edges positive why why am
I always sampling many more negative
edges than positive edges uh because the
the problem is really imbalanced right
in a sense that that um uh in a sense
that I know Netflix has uh you know
hundreds of thousands of movies my
Amazon has I know a billion products and
you only interact with a very small
number of them so so it's not a 50/50
it's it's very tiny so you want you you
need a lot of negative examples to kind
of push away the positive one
uh what's the issue like empirically
with the non-personalized loss is it
that it's wasted compute or is it that
like the best performance you could get
is not going to be as good with the
binary versus BPR uh good question so
what is the problem with the with the
binary loss uh in in practice what
happens is that the binary loss I mean
in some sense it's harder to optimize um
and it kind of lets the the model focus
on on kind of on wrong things right yes
if you'd have an all powerful model then
you'd say yeah I'll use binary because
it forces my model to even learn more
but in reality your data is noisy your
model is imperfect so now you're trying
to force model to learn something that
you don't really care about so it's
better to have a personalized loss
because it really tells the model what
you really care about and the model is
going to use the modeling power to
separate out items for a given user
rather than make items comparable across
users that's kind of the key why one is
better than the other but good point
yeah thank you yes for the Negative Edge
choices uh do you want the negative
edges to be closer to your required uh
sample or do you want it to be like very
dist great yeah good question how do I
select negative edges I'll I'll I have
slides at the end where I'll show you
how how to do this properly but the idea
is the following the idea is that if you
pick random things then and you know my
my baking example right then it becomes
too easy um for the model to learn
because it's really saying oh here is
baking and there's everything else right
but if you think about this candidate
generators they really need to pick the
not out of all baking items but you know
maybe I like you know whatever making
cookies that look cats and dogs right so
you want to recommend me I know cooking
stuff that makes cats and dogs I I'm
making this up as I go so let's see
where it takes me you know but but what
I'm trying to say is it's important to
force the model to really give you those
good items in the top 100 out of a
billion so you are really learning to
push the good stuff all the way to the
top and all the irrelevant stuff to the
bottom so the point is if you have
negative random negatives it's too easy
for the model to learn and it's too much
noise at the top so it never learns so
what you can then do is to start
introducing what is called hard negative
examples right so kind of you know
baking stuff that is not cats and dogs
so that you really learn how to
personalize baking stuff for me because
I'm in a very I know specific type of
baking right so so that's that's that's
what I mean by that and I'll show you
something that is called uh is called uh
distance-based sampling where you want
to kind of when sample negative examples
you want to make sure you sample them
kind of evenly across the embedding
distances because if you sample randomly
you know you are like sampling from far
away and it's easy if you sample too
close then you confuse the model because
you give it points that are very similar
but you don't tell you that those all
these other things are irrelevant so you
kind of have to sample across the range
of distances that's the that's the
intuition I'll make this more precise at
the end yes go ahead I was wondering is
the user always a single user or this
let's say a few user living in the same
house so they may buy similar item to
you is that possible that you will
consider set of the notes ins I one
single notes uh good question so your
question is about what what about people
who share passwords right that's
basically or you know people that use
the same account either Amazon or
Netflix and so on so the way you would
do this is you you'd try to model that
heterogeneity kind of um separately
outside You' either try to identify that
the user is heterogeneous and kind of
split the user into a couple of nodes
you'd like maybe to to to very quickly
try to identify what identity of the
user you are working with it's a very
hard I would say use case specific
specific problem if behind the same
identity there's actually multiple
multiple individuals or multiple
different tastes okay uh good um so why
do embedding uh thank you for the
questions uh let me continue um and
please ask me more right so um why do
embedding uh systems work um and there
is this super powerful intuition for a
commander systems that's called
collaborative
filtering and basically the
collaborative filtering the idea is that
by by that if you recommend items for a
user by collecting preferences of other
similar users you will do really really
well right in a sense that similar users
tend to prefer similar items right if
you and I watch 20 movies uh in common
on Netflix then probably the 20 first
movie we will watch will also be very
similar right so if I watch 20 movies
and you watch 21 and all the first 20
are the same then a very good
recommendation is to say whatever is
your 21st movie that's my 21st movie
that's that's the idea of collaborative
filtering where you can basically say
two users are similar if they interacted
with a lot of same items and then you
just look what what the other user has
interacted with that the first one
hasn't yet and that's the that's the
that's the that's a very good
recommendation that you would come up
with here and this embedding based graph
based methods do exactly that right they
will because uh these two users can
interacted with similar items they will
have similar embeddings um so whenever
you you uh and uh this particular it
user and that particular item will have
a high score because this is a positive
Edge so it means the user youu and this
particular item will also likely have a
high score that's kind of this uh um
collaborative filtering
intuition right so the key here is how
do we capture similarity between users
and items um and and embedding based
models basically allow you to capture
this uh really well because low
dimensional embeddings cannot are
basically forced to generalize in a
sense that they cannot simply uh capture
all the user item interaction data right
and the embeddings are forc to kind of
learn this implicit similarity between
users and items and this allows the
models to make effective prediction uh
on unseen user item interactions right
if you embedding dimensionality too
large then basically you can just
memorize the edges and you don't want to
do that so what you do is you make the
embedding dimensionality a bit smaller
to kind of force the model to identify
these similarities between between users
and items so what I want to tell uh in
the remaining of the lecture is actually
show you a few GNN based methods for a
commander systems right what we learned
so far was you can just do shallow
embeddings of users and shallow
embeddings of items the problem with
that is for example is that it's
transductive um and that uh you need to
learn this uh you need to learn this
embeddings I'm now going to show you uh
three methods uh the neural graph
collaborative filtering
the light gcn which is kind of a
simplification and then I'll tell you
about this um paper called pinage that
use that showed how to use gnm's to make
high quality uh embeddings for
recommendations and this is these are
the first two are kind of research
papers this is also a research paper but
it's a deployed system uh so um it's
kind of a lot of practical uh tips on
how to make things work and what really
matters okay so let's start with new
collaborative
filtering so the conventional collabor
filtering collaborative filtering is is
based on this shallow encoders which
means shallow embeddings we have no user
no item features um and uh we only you
know basically for every user and item
we prepare a shallow learnable learnable
embedding right we just directly learn
the embedding and usually the scoring
function people just use the dot product
usually the scoring function is just a
DOT product between the embedding of the
user and the embedding of the item
because it's then easy to do the nearest
neighbor search if you have a very
simple uh scoring function okay so
that's uh the way people uh usually do
it um but the problem with this shallow
encoders is that this does not
explicitly capture the graph structure
um and the graph structure is only
implicitly captured as part of the
training uh objective so uh what you
know the researchers in the paper say
that only kind of the first order graph
structure the edges is captured in the
training objective and the question is
could you kind of struct capture a bit
more of the graph structure explicitly
Beyond just individual edges um so the
motivation is that we want a model that
explicitly captures the graph structure
um Beyond just the the training
objective and that captures kind of more
bigger region of the graph rather than
just each Edge kind of individually and
here the GNN are a natural approach to
this and as I said I'll talk about the
neural graph collaborative filtering and
then uh a method called uh uh light uh
light gcn that's a simplified version of
the first method um but the neural
collaborative filtering explicitly
incorporates higher order graph
structure when generating user and item
embeddings and the key idea is to use
GNN to generate graph aware user item
EMB Bings in the initial
step we learn shallow embeddings of
users and items this is what I showed
you to do so far and then what this
paper proposes is to use a GNN to
propagate the embeddings um and and make
them more graph aware so what this means
is that use now GNN to kind of enrich an
embedding of every user and item through
the embeddings of nearby uh users and
items and you kind of smooth this
embeddings across the graph a bit you
reach them and you get um better
performance uh for that reason okay so
the way this works is we are given user
item uh bipartite graph um we pre we we
prepare shallow learnable embedding for
every node and then we use a multi-layer
GNN to propagate embeddings uh across
this uh bipartite graph um and then yeah
in this sense final embeddings are
explicitly graph aware uh then there are
two kinds of learnable parameters that
are jointly learned the shallow user
item embeddings as well as the
parameters uh of the GNN right so here
the way we would do it we would not
first train the the shallow embeddings
and then the GNN but we would kind of do
it one after the other right like we
would basically do them in a coordinate
descent Type of Way um so that we learn
both at the same time okay um now about
the initial node
embeddings we set a shallow learnable
embeddings uh that are uh um uh in that
basically are initial node features or
node embeddings for every user for uh
every uh every item we initialize this
uh
embedding and then we iteratively update
node embeddings using this kind of uh
neighborhood embeddings where you say
the the embedding of a given note at the
next iteration is a combination of of
the embedding of the same note at the
previous iteration plus aggregation of
the uh embeddings of neighbors um and
here we have uh two uh V are um uh
combining uh from items uh and we are
combining uh from uh from users right um
and different architectural choices are
possible for the aggregation and
combination aggregation could be mean uh
and combine can simply be like concat
and some um some linear layer um and and
and then a nonlinearity right so there's
a a lot kind of flexibility how exactly
uh you implement uh you implement this
part okay and then you know what are the
final embeddings in the score function
after K rounds of this neighborhood
aggregation we get a final embedding uh
H uh H uh h of U of of K and also the
the H of the item at K and then uh what
do we do I say the embeding of the user
is simply the eming at the the last
iteration and the embedding of the item
is the embedding at the last iteration
and then score function what people like
to use is just the dot product between
the embedding of the user and the
embedding uh of the item um so to
summarize what is uh neural graph
collaborative filtering does it's a
conventional collaborative filtering
method uses a shallow user item
embeddings um kind of and doesn't
explicitly model the graph structure so
the N GCF uses a GNN to propagate
shallow embeddings across the graphs um
and embeddings are explicitly aware of
kind of higher order uh graph structure
because of this propagation that's the
that's the key um Innovation here that
you get the benefit of shallow
embeddings but also um some smoothness
or propagation of the shallow embedding
across the graph using this learnable
GNN okay that's the that's the idea
here um so that's the the the first
method I don't know do people have any
questions or shall I show you the kind
of a simplified version of
this okay I'll show you I'll show you a
simplified and then please ask me a
question okay so the the next method I
want to show is called uh uh light GCM
uh and was also uh developed uh with
recommender systems uh in mind so here
is how how to think of this right the
the the neural graph collaborative
filtering joins jointly learns two kinds
of parameters the shallow user item
embeddings and the the GNN uh parameters
uh the observation is that this shallow
learnable EMB bearings are kind of
already already quite
expressive right they're learned for
every user and every item uh separately
um and if you look at where where are
the threee parameters most of the three
parameters are in the shallow embeddings
where the number of of items nodes uh
users is much bigger than the embedding
dimensionality right because the amount
of parameters in the um in the shallow
EMB banding is n * D and the GNN will
have kind of this squared number of
parameters right the the um or that
order right so there is much more
modeling power here than here so um what
the intuition is that maybe these GNN uh
parameters are not so uh essential in
this so the question is can we simplify
the GNN part um and uh maybe make uh the
model uh more more efficient easier to
learn and the answer is yes and what
people have also found is that actually
it gives you a slight boost um in
performance uh again on benchmarks as
well so let's take a look at how does
this
work we the idea goes as follows we are
going to have an adjacency Matrix for
the bipartite graph and I'm going to use
the Matrix formulation of the gcn of the
graph convolutional neural network right
this is I know lecture 4 five something
like that right Jan was talking about
this uh Matrix formulation of a gcn um
and then we are actually going to
simplify the gcn by removing
nonlinearity um and this is similar to
this method um that is called SGC um
that is for scalable GNN and I think uh
this lecture will come uh next week or
in two weeks okay so we are going to
learn about this and the the two the two
ideas are related so let me now tell you
about this light light light GCM so we
are going to take the adjacency Matrix
of an undirected bipartite graph so the
way the way the adjacency Matrix of a
bipartite graph looks like there are two
blocks of zeros because items don't link
to items and users don't link to users
but there are non zero non zero entries
here and here and one is uh the
transposed version of the other because
the graph is by is is um undirected okay
here are you V is one if the user U
interacts with item v um and zero
otherwise um and then we also have an
embedding Matrix that has the embeddings
of all the users and the embeddings of
all the items okay that's the uh that's
the that's the
setting so now I I show you try to kind
of uh remind you what was The Matrix
formulation of a of a gcn um and the key
concept here is this notion of a
diffusion Matrix um and another
connection between the lecture today and
what we are going to talk about now is
the connection to this correct and
smooth method that was I don't know
lecture nine or something um where we
talked about this uh semi-supervised
correct correct and smooth method that
was propagating the labels across the
graph and uh the key concept there was
this notion of a diffusion Matrix where
we have D to be a degree Matrix so this
is a diagonal matrix that has degrees of
nodes on the diagonal um and then we
Define this a TIA as a normalized
adjacency matrix to be the to be the um
the degree Matrix times The adjacency
Matrix times the the properly processed
uh degree Matrix okay and then let e of
K be the embeding Matrix at the case
layer and again the embedding Matrix is
simply each row stores an embedding of a
of a uh um of a proper node the
difference uh here between the gcn the
original gcn formulation is that here
there is no self connections right in
the gcn we added a self Loop to every
node here we don't
okay and then each layer of gcn
agregation can be written in The Matrix
form this was that uh lecture that I was
referring to where basically you can
take this uh diffusion Matrix um
embeddings uh at a layer K the the
weight Matrix to transform the
embeddings send it through a
nonlinearity and you get embeddings at
the next layer so that's uh kind of um a
matrix version of a graph neural network
where you work with the entire graph at
once and you propagate step by step from
all the nodes using here basically what
happens is neighborhood aggregation
right because you are taking a AJ Matrix
and and multiplying it with the
embedding Matrix um and these are the
learnable linear
Transformations right so that's the
that's the that's the idea here so what
does now light gcn
does light gcn says if you are iterating
this equation up there and you remove
the nonlinearity right I I had a r here
now I removed it and and now my
iteration says that e k + 1 equal 8 Thea
* z k * w k right then the final if I
take this recursion and kind of expand
it then basically I say e of K is AA e k
minus1 * w k minus one so I can take
this e k and throw it into that Cas so
here is what I get right and now I can
expand this and I get uh AA * AA time e
Kus 2 W uh Kus 2 w K minus one okay and
you can see now that I can take this one
and further uh replace further kind of
unfold my recursion okay and at the end
when I have unrolled this all the way to
the zero this is what I will get okay
I'll get this multiplications of a TIA K
times then I'll get the the e z the
initial embeddings and then I'll get
these parameter matrices multiplied uh k
um uh multiplied together okay but
what's the point the point is that this
a tildas this is just AA raised to the
power of capital K this e z are the
embeddings and all these parameter
matrices don't really matter because I
can just collapse them together into a
single parameter Matrix okay so what is
simplifies to it simplifies to the
following thing it says that the
embedding Matrix at layer K is simply
the uh a ra to the power K time initial
embeddings times uh parameter Matrix W
okay um and this basically means that
I'm diffusing node embeddings along the
graph in a similar way that what correct
and smooth uh did using the soft labels
uh in the graph so what's the algorithm
algorithm that these people are
proposing is that you are simply running
this you take e multiply it with a Tilda
to get new e put it here a Tilda and so
on right so each matrix multiplication
diffuses the current embeddings to one
hot uh neighbors and note right that a
to the K is a dense um Matrix so if I
run this as an iteration this a raised
to the power of K never really gets
materialized right so I don't have to
materialize this a the raised to the
power of K because this will become a
very dense Matrix because every Power um
creates connects nodes that are two hops
away this was something I explained in
the first second lecture if you guys
remember okay so um this basically
iterative Matrix Vector product is
useful to compute this expression but
much more scalable because I'm just
doing this multiplication several times
okay so this is the basic version of
this
algorithm what people do in reality is
they call what they say multiscale
diffusion right so what they say is they
say let's um they say basically let's
weigh uh contribution from nodes that
are farther out less than from than from
the nodes that are close Okay so the way
they do it is they come up with this
weights alpha alpha zero alpha 1 Alpha
two and so on um and this is now
multiscale because this uh um Neighbors
at different layers contribute different
amount um and this includes embeddings
diffused at kind of multihop scales um
and this uh uh you know Alpha here is
how you can write it out right like
alpha alpha 0 * e0 equal Alpha 0 uh a
TAA 0 and E Z XS as a as a as a self
connection that that is omitted in the
definition of uh a a Tilda and the
coefficients this alpha0 to Alpha K are
hyper parameters and what do people like
to do for example just as a way to set
this Alpha parameters Li gcn uses this
uh uh uniform coefficient where
basically they say Alpha K is just 1
minus k + 1 so here um uh um uh the the
they would actually set the alpha to be
uh to be to be the same for all uh Alpha
0 to Alpha capital K okay so uh how does
this work let me uh let me try to
summarize this so basically we are going
to iteratively diffuse em embedding
Matrix e using this a TIA Matrix that I
that I discussed right um so from little
K going from Zer to K minus one
I'm going to take the um embedding uh
the current embedding M Matrix and then
basically I'm going to multiply it with
this normalized adjacency Matrix l a TIA
with cell flop omitted to get the next
level uh embedding Matrix and then I'm
going to put this uh here and multiply
again and I'm going to iterate this for
uh capital K uh number of steps um yeah
yes uh two questions the first one is if
you are Amazon and you have a billion
products how are you doing this I mean
are you doing this matrix multiplication
all in memory and then the second one is
is is this related is this sort of like
a generalization of the cat's Matrix to
The normalized adjacency Matrix uh two
good questions so the first question was
uh uh about uh about scale um yeah
multiplying big matrices is not a
problem uh uh I don't know how to say if
you take my class in the spring you'll
see you can you can multiply really
really huge matrices uh uh if need be
you can even use map reduce and you can
uh you can multiply The Matrix
describing the entire web and things
like that so so so this multiplication
yes it's non-trivial but you can you can
do what becomes a bottleneck is uh is uh
storing these embeddings but you can
distribute them across machines you can
distribute parts of this Matrix across
machines you know you you you need some
engineering but but it's very solvable
um and then the second question was
about Cuts is this similar to Cuts yes
it's similar right it's similar in a
sense that in Cuts we had these Alphas
as well but they were decaying
exponentially right and then there was
this closed Forum that that we discussed
here this Alphas are um uh you know this
people decided to choose it this way um
it's a good question why it's a good
question what would do if you do uh if
you do not lights gcn but you do a cuts
gcn um it'd be cool to at least spend
some time on Google Scholar and see if
anyone has tried to do that but it's a
it's an interesting question so what the
authors propose here is that basically
you store all these intermediate
embedding matrices and at the end you
just average them together right this is
this uniform alpha right you just kind
of average them together and that gives
you your final um your final embedding
Matrix okay so that's the overview of
this method where rather than iterating
and taking the last one you you remember
the intermediate ones as well and
average them up into your uh final
embeding for the users uh and for the uh
for the items and then as I said the
score function um is simply a DOT
product you take a user you take an item
U you dot product the two vectors and
that will be uh that will be uh that
will be your score okay so uh that's
about this uh light gcn that is um kind
of amazingly simple you only take this
adjacency Matrix you you uh post process
pre-process it using the degree Matrix
um and then you run and then you run the
uh and then you run the uh you run the
iteration right so the overview is you
are given the um uh uh adjacency Matrix
you take this initial learnable uh
embedding Matrix e right so I use the
shallow and banding Matrix C that I
learn ahead of time and then basically
all I need to do is take the adjacency
Matrix normalize it to this a Tilda and
then multiply this learn embedding
Matrix with itself couple of times and
then average the results right so the
light gcn in this respect is a
postprocessing step where in the first
step I learn the shallow embeddings
using the BPR loss or or whatever and
then I um I uh propagate these
embeddings uh or multiply them several
times with the normalized adjacency
Matrix average those resulting embedding
matrices together to get kind of a
better version of embeddings right so in
this light gcn there is no learning
after I learned the initial
embeddings okay so that's the uh that's
the that's the key idea here um right
and you know why does this simple
diffusion uh propagation uh work so well
um the answer is that diffusion directly
encourages the embeddings of similar
users items uh to be similar right so
similar users share many common
neighbors uh items and are in this
respect expected to have similar future
preferences which means that when you
are um aggregating these embeddings from
similar users and averaging them you are
in some sense uh U amplifying this
similarity uh between between users and
you could make the same argument for
items is the two items are similar if uh
they have a lot of uh users in common
who interact with them so that's the um
that's the that's the idea
here
um I maybe want to just make a quick
comparison to kind of situate the light
uh gcn and the original gcn and also the
correct and smooth method and say what
the differences were is that the
embedding propagation in gcn is close in
Li gcn is closely related to these other
two methods um and in gcn and correct
and smooth uh the way the way we did it
we said that uh in terms of propagation
when we sum over the the neighbors we
normalize the embeddings by the one over
the square root of uh um of the product
of the degrees of uh node U and uh uh
node uh node uh node v um and we had the
self Loop to be kind of a spark of this
iteration um the light gcn uses kind of
a the same equation except that the cell
flop is not added in the neighborhood
definition um and final embedding takes
the average from embeddings from all
layers right so the final embedding is
the sum of the individual layer
embeddings rather than saying the final
embedding is the final layer embedding
right so h of V is not not h of V at
capital K but is a sum of H of vs for K
is going from zero up to capital K so
those are the two um the two key uh the
two key differences so
um with this let me just um
summarize um what this SL gcn did is it
took this neural graph conol filtering
by by basically removing the learning
parameters of the GNN um and uh now all
the learnable parameters are in the
shallow uh input uh node and bearings um
and the diffusion propagation only
involves Matrix Vector multipli
multiplication and the simplication
leads to a bit better um empirical
performance so that's what I wanted to
say about um kind of the the core two
methods that we wanted to talk about
today I'm now happy to um to take
questions um I see your hands and what
I'll do after the questions I'll tell
you about an industrial deployment uh of
GNN for recommendation systems it's
called pin Sage um and this runs and was
developed at Pinterest to uh to a to a
huge success I would say so I can say
more yes uh is there an intuition why uh
the graph aware embeddings are better
than the one hop embeddings because I
think the intuition you provided I
didn't fully understand where the
benefit is um given that it's like a
bipar graph it seems like even with one
hop embeddings you're getting like
embeddings where the nodes are similar
if their neighbors are similar so is
there an intuition for the type of graph
aware feature that you might be
interested in yes good question so why
why does this why does this help and the
reason the reason it helps is because it
kind of Smooths explicitly the Bings
across the graph a bit right and and and
uh your objective function kind of
doesn't enforce any smoothness right
doesn't EXC say Hey you have to be
similar because you are connected right
yes there is some ter term in there but
there's a lot of other terms as well
while the the this smoothing uh type
things they really kind of
force um embeddings to be more to be
more similar across connection so I
would say in some sense it's you know it
Smooths the data it maybe denises the
data a bit and that's why you get added
um why you get uh added benefit it might
be also that some users are very noisy
but you are still just training them
based on their own data but now because
you take some other user you kind of the
the the information it stabilizes uh the
user itself so it kind of averages the
embeddings a bit across the graph makes
them more smooth and actually makes them
a bit more stable because
uh yes yeah this idea of summing all
your uh H vectors of all layers cannot
um is this like specific to this type of
problem or can that also be like
transferred to previous prediction tasks
um yeah because it doesn't seem nice
specific to this great question uh great
question you so the question I'm
repeating because I don't think people
online are hearing uh the question was
this averaging of embeddings AC cross
layers um uh is different than what
we've been what we've been doing so far
because we always said oh the embedding
is the final layer embedding right um
and you are saying is this a general
approach or is this some because it it's
doesn't look like it's related to
recommander systems I would say yes you
are correct you could try this strategy
elsewhere as well originally it's been
developed in the context of recommender
systems and that's also um where where
uh it gives uh probably the best
performance but yeah it's a more it's a
more general idea so that's a good
observation anything
else okay so let me um let me tell you
about uh uh this uh uh pinage or
Pinterest recommender system that's uh
graph based um what is the idea the idea
is that um given a query image you want
recommend related images or uh related
pins um and the way you want to do this
is that you want to create this
embedding of a pin right and a pin is
not just the image it also includes a it
includes it includes a description like
you see here and it also includes uh the
graph information um and for a while
this was the largest industrial
deployment uh of gnns that uh that got
hugely adopted across all kinds of
products and services across uh
Pinterest um and uh it it um it it
allows you to basically both do fresh
content so as soon as you as a new as a
new PIN is created it's basically
embedded in in this pin embedding space
and and then these embeddings are
consumed uh down the down the line um
and uh the the core of this approach is
the is a graph convolutional neural
network um and the goal is to create
embeddings of nodes uh in in a large
scale uh Pinterest graph and I'm going
to explain with tens hundreds of
billions of objects um and the key idea
here was to really borrow information
from nearby uh from nearby nodes what
happens if you only use um visual
information to train your your models
then you make mistakes like this right
you confuse a steel fence for a for a
rail of a bed you confuse um ground meat
and soil you confuse a a rug and a
tapestry so you create these things that
look visually the same but are
semantically completely different um so
it is essential um to have a high
quality embedding that you can then use
for a lot of different tasks for you
know from search to ads to content
safety and so on and so forth so now how
how how was this built right what is the
key um component of what Pinterest users
do is that they kind of you can think of
it as they they are like looking at
these images and they are uh collecting
them in different boards so they are
creating this bipartite graph between
pins and boards and board is just a
collection of images right so so maybe
somebody's interested in uh man style
how to dress well and they are browsing
images and say oh I like this one I like
that one then they add them together and
then some other user you know might be
might be also collecting how men can
dress well and somebody else might be
into plants so they are collecting
different Arrangements of plants and uh
you know somebody might be in
architecture and so on and so forth so
we have billions of these boards where
people kind of curate content and
especially if you're doing Home
Remodeling if you want to figure out how
to do how to throw a birthday party or
something usually people create a board
and then browse and say oh these are
ideas I like it's almost like window
shopping okay so in this graph we have
two types of nodes we have the pins and
we have these boards right and this is
and the link is that a pin belongs to a
board and a same pin can belong to
multiple boards um and the graph has
tens of billions of nodes and edges um
and the way we we create an embedding of
a node is that basically especially of a
pin is that basically we have a gcn
across this across this graph right at
the bottom layer we are going to have um
um embed embeddings or features of
individual pins this would be images and
so on but then we have a gcn that
Aggregates this so what this means is
that the embedding of a given pin will
depend on uh the embeddings of other
pins that that are that it shares uh
boards with and now you can basically
back propagate into this gcn to learn
how to optimally collect information
from neighbors to uh to uh create an
embedding of a given object and why does
this help is because a a a garden fence
is going to be to be pinned with other
garden fences some of those garden
fences will really look like a garden
fence so even the garden fence that
seems to look like a bed railing will
collect you know embeddings of other
garden fences and say hey actually I'm
not a bad rail I'm a I'm a garden fence
right and a bad will say what am I with
and it will be pinned with good-look
beds so that bed will say Hey you know
I'm truly a bad right so that's kind of
the intuition uh what's uh what's
happening uh here and what's interesting
in this in this work is that um uh in
addition to the model the The Innovation
the paper introduces several methods to
scale up G gcn to this billion billion
note scale and to the production
workloads and I'll give you a few examp
examples one was across uh negative
samples that there was a question
earlier um um especially around hard
negatives curriculum learning and also
mini batch training of uh gcn right
usually people would have this Matrix
formulation of a GNN this was one of the
first papers that kind of said hey let's
do the mini batch with the explicit uh
uh sampling of the computation graphs uh
and learning over that so the way this
system was supervised was supervised on
a on a on a in some sense link
prediction task where the idea is that I
want to recommend related pins to the
user so I have a query I have a
successful recommendation and an
unsuccessful recommendation and the
objective function was that you know the
distance between the the query and the
positive recommendation has to be
smaller than the query um and the and
the sweater so the the gnns will go this
way and then you know here is where the
score gets computed and then back
propagation goes through this kind of
two Tower um
architecture um in terms of training
data um you know this was this was a few
years back but even then they were
training on over a a billion over a
billion uh pairs um and here are some
examples of positive uh positive
training examples right um and what's
interesting is that sometimes you know
um they might be quite different but
they are related right this is about SE
and this is or this is Sailors here is
Navy even though you know this is
something to put on the door or
something and here's a mug and so on and
so forth so they have um a lot of
examples of positive uh training
pairs um one Innovation to make this
scale is this sharing of negative
examples right that in a VPR loss for
every user in a mini batch we sample one
positive interaction and then a set of
negative uh interaction
um and using more negative samples per
user improves recommendation performance
but also slows down training because you
have to create these negative examples
over and over again so right if you want
to have some number of positive users
then for each one you need to create
some number of negative examples and
this this can become uh quite expensive
okay so um what do they what what is the
idea idea is that we can share the
negative examples across all users in
the mini batch so the idea is that while
positive examples are user specific now
the negative examples are are the same
for all the users uh in the mini batch
this way we only need to generate uh um
uh um uh uh whatever is the number of
negative examples uh embeddings uh for
negative nodes and we don't have to
resample negative examples uh every time
for uh for each user um and this saves a
lot of node embedding generation a lot
of computation uh by basically the the
factor of the size of your uh mini batch
um and empirically empiric the
performance stays about similar um but
you have just sped up your computation
by a by a by a big by a big amount so
that's the
first and then the second one is this
idea of
hard negatives and this goes to the
questions I was getting earlier right
that you basically in this industrial
Commander systems you need to make this
extremely fine grain predictions right
you have billions of items but then you
only care about top 10 top 100 so um the
issue is that shared negative examples
you know in principle are randomly
sampled from all users so most of them
are kind of easy negatives right it's so
easy to to recognize what's a positive
example versus negative examples so what
you want to do is create this notion of
a hard negative and let me give you an
idea right if this is a source this is a
query and that's a positive example
right then if I just pick a random PIN
you know it's some random Cottage some
somewhere in the wood it's very easy to
say this is a positive pair and that's a
negative pair but if I but this is an
example of a hard negative example right
it looks so these are two you know thank
you very much you are special type of
cards and this kind of looks like a card
but it's not if you see this is
something you you can put on a t on a
desk and it says happy birthday right so
this is a hard negative example and if I
just have this random negatives I'll be
learning to make distinction between
these two and that two and that's very
easy so I'll never learn to the level to
say oh actually this is not related this
is very different okay so you have this
notion of uh hard negative negative
examples and the key Insight is to apply
this technique of um curriculum learning
where you make negative examples uh
gradually harder and harder as the
process goes so that the model kind of
focuses on hard to distinguish parts of
the space and really learns these fine
grained uh
distinctions um I'll uh you know there
are a lot of heuristics how you set hard
negative examples at some point in time
they were saying oh let's look at you
know something that is ranked at rank
2,000 to 5,000 and maybe say that those
are negative examples but the correct
way to do this is this distance-based
sampling so here's the here is the key
plot that I want to show to you so this
is the distance between examples right
um and if you do un so this is distance
zero and uh you know this is kind of
distance Infinity think of it that way
right if you do um uniform sampling then
basically most of the pins are unrelated
so they'll be very far away so your you
know your positive example is close but
then this exists this Gap and there's
and then uh there are your negative
examples so if you do this hard negative
examples that I showed you then you then
you sample from this region so you have
a positive example this region and that
region again it's not good so um but if
you use this distance weight sampling
then you kind of sample your negatives
along the entire distance spectrum and
that really makes the model learn best
because you give it examples of all
kinds of hardnesses rather than giving
it super easy or super hard uh examples
and if you do this then you get really
really good results right so here's a
query pin and this is the visual
embeddings nearest neighbors and here
are the graph based um nearest neighbors
and you can see how basically you know
this is not bad but this is definitely
better right and you get some you get
some mistakes so um my last slide and
then finish so the this pinage uses GNN
to generate high quality user and item
embeddings that capture reach node
attributes as well as uh the graph
structure um the kind of the key
Innovation was scaling and the notion of
negative sampling um and uh um you know
uh if you um um to you know uncovered
topic of this lecture is how do we scale
gnn's up to large scale and I'm going to
talk uh talk about this either I think
in the next one or two lectures so this
is what's uh yet coming but uh I hope
you like the lecture and um thank you so
much